buonasera
quante volte oggi avete usato la parola
impossibile
e quante volte solitamente usiamo parole
impossibili ai nostri giorni
beh se l'avete fatto avete sbagliato
perché la parola impossibile non esiste
e vi posso dare un esempio quando mi
hanno invitato a partecipare al ted mi
hanno detto che si doveva trovare il
modo di condensare in pochissimo tempo
tra i discorsi importanti come ted magia
e acqua e questo mi sembrava piuttosto
difficile
bene anche quel caso lì ho usato per ora
impossibile
perché
per realizzare l'impossibile basta
pensare come un mago se io vi chiedessi
di far sparire la statua della libertà
voi che cosa mi dareste impossibile
eppure un mago un uomo ce l'ha fatta
david copperfield che ha fatto sparire
l'interessato della libertà questo è
molto semplice perché un mago
solitamente ha ragione noi solitamente
ragioniamo secondo un pensiero dati cara
visto the rico per andare da a a b
andiamo giù in verticale il mago invece
che cosa fa ci gira attorno e segue una
strada che noi non vediamo e quindi
questa strada che prende un mistero
farò bocca e genera la magia mi sono
spiegato
vabbè possa essere più chiaro io oggi
voglio svelarvi un segreto il più grande
segreto di tutti non semplici prestigio
ma il segreto per realizzare
l'impossibile nella vita di tutti i
giorni
prima però lo state le due promesse che
riguardo al modulo e magia la prima il
mago non inganna perché il mago la
persona più onesta che ci sia
difatti promette di ingannarvi e poi
mantiene la sua promessa
la seconda cosa invece è che solitamente
tutti sospettano che i maghi nascondono
le cose nelle maniche e vero mi serve
una persona che vi pressi una giacca a
una giacca
questo grazie stia pure allora di per se
questo è importante non sono le maniche
dei maghi essere toccate ma sono le
maniche degli spettatori
grazie che continuiamo a parlare di
acqua
in realtà la più grande magia di un mago
e più grande segreto quello che rende
veramente speciale il prestigio e la
capacità di un mago non di trovare
soluzioni a problemi apparentemente
impossibili ma di creare premesse che
generano problemi irrisolvibili
ok per essere più semplici un mago non è
un esperto di proves setti di problem
solving e un esperto di prove setting
cioè crea dei problemi che noi non
riusciamo a capire
vi faccio un esempio questo è uno dei
giochi più classici e più famosi del
mondo ma anche più difficile la moneta
che scompare la moretta nella mano e il
mago lo fa sparire quasi una falsa
promessa fortissima cioè che il mago
abbia messo la moneta nella mano provate
a pensare a pensavo in questo modo se il
mago non avesse messo la moneta della
mano
ovviamente tutto questo sarebbe molto
più semplice
adesso avete tutte le premesse perché
vive nel senso che le premesse che la
moneta non sia nella mano oppure c'è
un'altra falsa promessa che la moneta
non si è mai esistita
grazie vi racconterò di come sia
possibile trasmette traslare tutto
questo è una vita reale proprio dice sì
ok tutto bello bellissimo ma come si fa
a portare questo nella vita di tutti i
giorni come si fa a realizzare
l'impossibile nella vita di tutti i
giorni
e molto semplice di per sé tutti noi
ogni giorno ci diamo dei degli obiettivi
che riteniamo impossibili perché
riteniamo che non sia possibile
realizzarli
in realtà non è vero basta soltanto
cambiare le premesse per esempio
realizza un fatturato che attualmente ci
sembrano raggiungibile oppure prende 30
un esame
oppure che ne so conosce una persona ci
sono tantissimi sogni che noi ci
precludiamo è che non riusciamo a
raggiungere soltanto perché non cambiamo
le promesse
in pratica il pensiero illusionistico
non è nient'altro che una forma mentis
che ci aiuta a scovare le premesse
sbagliate
vi racconterò tra storie la storia di un
mago di un uomo di un militare che ha
cambiato destino della seconda guerra
mondiale la storia di un artista che ha
rivoluzionato il concetto di arte
moderna e vi svelerà segreti più
importante di tutti come sia possibile
scegliere di essere felici 1942 guerra
d'africa
gli inglesi sono accerchiati e i
tedeschi hanno praticamente la meglio in
tutte le battaglie
questo perché alla guida dei tedeschi
c'è il fair marshall rommel che molti
considerano dotato di poteri paranormali
perché riesce addirittura pare a
prevedere le mosse dei generali degli
avversari allora gli inglesi contrastare
un presunto mago inviano giu nel deserto
tra il sabbio deserto un vero
illusionista e jasper maschera in è una
storia vera è una storia vera di un uomo
che è riuscito a cambiare gestione la
seconda guerra mondiale pensando come un
mago
lui era l'ultimo discendente di sette
generazioni di maghi aveva un teatro sua
londra le 1 e le voodoo e dando
bombardato rimasto senza teatro senza
lavoro e si è arruolato volontario ed è
partito della guerra d'africa ed è
riuscito a far sparire il porto di
alessandria il canale di suez e un
intero esercito pensa al venduti a
battaglia quella dire la main entrata
nella storia perché mentre rommel
aspettava l'attacco da nord l'esercito
inglese apparso come per magia
come se fosse proprio comparso da sud
ma la sua cosa più affascinante più
geniale è stata la spedizione del
prodotto interessante vi racconto come
successa alessandra ha una baia vicino
che è praticamente identica ma
ovviamente non nel porto di alessandria
e lui ha costruito in quella baia uno
stesso sistema di luci di illuminazione
di cantiere del porto vero quando di
notte gli aerei tedeschi sono passati
per bombardare
lui ha spento le luci del porto vero è
acceso le luci del porto finto ma questo
non è stata l'unico colpo di genio
l'unico pensare con un mago quello che
ha reso veramente speciale la sua
strategia è che a terra ha fatto
scoppiare delle mine nuotare che quando
it e gli aerei son passati hanno visto
il min e scoppiano impensato del capo
squadriglia veste sganciato e così hanno
sganciato tutti quanti
e in pratica così l'esercito tedesco ha
bombardato per una notte intera in porto
di cartapesta
ma qual è la mascherina diciamo
scardinato tantissime false premesse ma
la più importante è quella di aver
convinto i tedeschi che una serie di
luci che disegnavano un porto in realtà
non fossero un porto ma solo una
rappresentazione del reale e questo ci
introduce la seconda storia che devo
raccontare e della storia di un artista
che ha cambiato che ha scardinato una
premessa fondamentale la premessa che
l'arte beh lui è anche altri l'arte
fosse solo un modo per rappresentare la
realtà in un modo più o meno preciso in
più o meno puntuale questo artista e
magritte pittore surrealista belga nato
nel 1989 che ha utilizzato per la prima
volta l'arte come forma di comunicazione
non so se avete presente il suo dipinto
più famoso che se si ne parlo in pipe e
affascinante perché lui è stato il primo
a inserire una scritta in un quadro e
questa è già di per sé una falsa
promessa perché questo non è una pippa
ma voi tutti avete e no perdincibacco
questa è una pippa
no perché non si può toccare non si può
fumare non si può prendere in mano
quindi è soltanto la rappresentazione di
una
pippa è chiaro vi faccio un esempio che
aiuta a chiarire meglio il funzionamento
allora scusate io disegno malissimo però
facciamo un esempio che cos'è questa non
c'è occhio key oppure potrebbe essere
una palla perfetta e così una palla da
bowling però non è una palla da bowling
e magari perché perché non può s'alzava
non possiamo e tre dita dente nella
rotola quindi questa non è una palla da
fermo anche ok però anche questa è una
falsa promessa perché la fase premesse
illusionistica perché in realtà vi ho
convinto che questo non sia una palla ma
se voi pensate con un mago avesse
all'altezza
grazie
e adesso piace un sacco fa questo
vi voglio raccontare quella che la magia
più bella di tutte io ho sempre pensato
che il pensiero lesionistico fosse utile
soltanto nelle cose pratiche invece poco
più di due anni fa ho cambiato idea ho
capito che si può con la magia o
cambiando le premesse scegliere di
essere felici qual è la premessa
sbagliata
solitamente noi pensiamo che la felicità
dipende da quello che stiamo vivendo
in realtà non è così perché se ci
pensate ci sono moltissime persone che
hanno oggettivamente molti problemi
eppure hanno energia pazzesca e son
pieni di vita e sono felici mentre altri
che hanno avuto tutto dalla vita che
sono depressi diciamo che mi piace
pensare che la felicità non sia uno
stato d'animo ma un modo di vedere la
vita
basta solo cambiare le promesse mi
permette raccontarvi cosa è successo a
me circa due anni fa è un venerdì sera
come tanti che aveva una cena di lavoro
sai quando ti vesti bene perché questo e
ben vestito una cena importante dotare
di un progetto al quale tenevo molto era
il ristorante milano ed alle 21 e 45
erano seduti vicini a questa persona
certo punto ci sembra stato il vino quei
piccoli dettagli che ti avevano in testa
ci sembra affatto il vino e mentre
stiamo parlando più subito della
conversazione o certo punto ho sentito
rumor lontano come per farvi un esempio
quello che ho sentito io come se
immaginate di essere 100 all'ora in
autostrada e cercasse di mettere di
violenza la prima data a ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta e immediatamente subito dopo il
tavolo si è ribaltato e tutto il
bicchiere di vino mi si è rovesciato
sulla maglia beh credo che sia capitato
a tutti deve una piccola macchiolina edf
arrabbiati
era proprio il vestito più bello sul
momento più bello e e aveva una macchia
così ok mi sono indispettito
permettetemi di dire indispettito
comunque abbiamo aveva accettato il
tavolo abbiamo iniziato a parlare un po
fatica e dopo 11 minuti 11
ricordatevi questo numero undici minuti
ho sentito di una volta ta ta ta ta ta
ta ta ta
il tavolo si è ribaltato di nuovo e io e
da quel momento in poi non ho più
pensato neanche per un secondo a quella
macchia non mi interessava più perché da
lì
un unico intento un unico la mia
priorità di vita era di salvarmi la vita
quel ristorante era il ponte numero pato
della costa concordia i venerdì era il
venerdì 13 gennaio del 2012 e quindi ho
capito una cosa importante che questi
sono stati gli unici minuti più
importanti della mia vita perché mentre
il mondo si stava muovendo
io magari dopo 11 minuti sarei potuto
essere morto e io ho sprecato gli 11
punti più importanti la mente a pensare
una macchia quante macchie ci sono nella
nostra vita che non contano
e allora ho cambiato le premesse e
quando mi capita qualche cosa che che
non va un problema un qualche cosa che
non mi funziona sposta le lancette della
mia mente avanti di 11 minuti e mi
chiedo questa cosa conta o non conta
e alla fine tutte quelle cose mi fanno
sprecare emozioni che mi fanno spaccare
gocce di vita non contano mai però non
dico che anzi vi auguro mi capiti mai
nella vive una tragedia per capire che
si possono cambiare le premesse però
provate a pensare a spostare la vostra
vita avanti di 11 minuti
tutte le volte che che proprio cosa
concorde parlo con qualcuno mi avete
quanto che il mondo è diviso in due
parti
ci sono quelli che che mi dicono circa
il 95 per cento mamma mia che sfortuna
che hai avuto
e poi c'è un 5 per cento piccolo che mi
dice mamma mia che fortuna che ha avuto
hai vissuto un miracolo sulla stessa
cosa
certo la cosa concordia è stata una
tragedia ma per noi per me che sono
sopravvissuto a me piace pensare che
abbia ragione quel 5 per cento e che
egli aveva vissuto un miracolo io credo
che si possa decidere e scegliere
cambiando le premesse di vivere ogni
giorno un miracolo quindi vi chiedo da
domani quale premesse cambierete per
trasformare ogni giorno in un miracolo
quali premesse cambierete per scegliere
di essere felici